[Music]
I'm in the center of this massive body
of water the Pacific
Ocean something incredible happened here
about 800 years ago in a seemingly
unbelievable coincidence two
archaeological wonders just appeared in
the
Pacific one Easter Island where seafires
erected giant Stone
heads and the other the even more
enigmatic civilization that built a
place called
namad a legendary complex of man-made
islands and stone structures built right
into the coral
reef that's where I'm
headed my name is Albert
Lynn and I look at the world in a unique
way I use 21st century technology to
look back into the past
check that out I can actually fly
through the secret ancient
world with lasers and scann
deserts strip away dense jungle canopy
and scour the oceans to uncover the
Hidden Worlds
beneath we're waiting into uncharted
waters now I had the military helping me
find lost cities new discoveries in the
most awe inspiring places on on Earth
that's where pixels become reality that
fill in the gaps in our
story who we are where we came from and
the Brilliance that we're capable of
here we are in the 13th
century this is carved out of the earth
huh this is the new Golden Age of
Exploration we know their
secrets
Pompei Island
Micronesia one of the most isolated
places on
Earth almost 1,000 M from the nearest
land mass it's taken four flights and
over 28 8 hours of travel just to get
here time to go my contact is local
historian Gus
ker welcome toi thanks brother how was
the trip amazing yeah yeah
amazing what is NAD nanad was once the
residents of the ruling South Dynasty
about 6 to 800 years ago
this an ancient city you'd be amazed
they know how that they had to build the
city in the
water I've heard it's an ancient wonder
rivaling Easter Island or matchup
Picchu but very little of it is still
visible so I'm bringing technology that
will strip away the mang Groves and
reveal its
scale
it's an Explorer's
dream we're superstitious people we
believe uh that it's invested by Spirits
so we will have to first of all go
through the king or the N Marquee as
they refer to and ask for his protection
and permission to enter the site this is
the custom that we do here there's been
rumors of people dying when they don't
follow protocol dying yes this really
happened it did
so what do I have to do to get
permission we will have to do what we
call a Saka
ceremonium the Saka root is pounded on a
special stone to create a powerful
narcotic drink used for religious
rituals I know that other Pacific
Islanders use toow in a similar
way I have to drink
that the purpose of our presentation
before our King is to ensure that the
spirits of our ancestors welcome you
when you visit nanad
Albert I me my heart's pounding right
now my whole mouth is
num like when you go to the dentist I
can barely feel my tongue right
now all who wish to enter NAD must pay
their
respects the spirits we're hoping to
appease are those of the saor the
legendary rulers who arrived here 800
years ago and held a mysterious power
over the Island's population those who
built
nadle we come here with a feeling of
honor to be here in your land thank
you ceremony complete the full power
this a cow drink kicks in yeah I got you
I got
you I see like double it's intense it's
intense but the most important thing is
the king of this land said that he
protects
us which means we're a
go so
tomorrow it's
on and I'm a
[Music]
do
this is it Albert Welcome to the
Jungle we are on secret grounds right
now you're just beginning to see part of
the structures I've never seen anything
like
this welcome to
nanad only a tiny fragment of the
legendary saor City can still be
seen mangroves choke whatever else
remains Now new technology can help
unblock the secrets of this
place how and why it was built and just
how big it really
is what is
that it's incredible ain't it I was born
here but every time I come up here I'm
always amazed
always this is the main ceremonial
Center of
[Music]
nanad it's a temple to the Island's
ancient rulers constructed from pillars
of balt
Rock 800 years ago this place would have
been bustling with hundreds of priests
attendants and the feared sador
Kings
must been some superpowered humans to
build this huh well this area was meant
only for the
lead it was the only time in our history
that we were ruled by one person almost
like a dictator so he was able to
command all the people on the island to
come and assist in the building of NAD
look is that more rocks over there is
that more yes that's an other wall
buildt all the way to the edge of the
reef yeah you can see the reef breaking
right there exactly it's massive
to get to grips with this city in the
sea we need to work out the full extent
of it and that can only be done from
above I think we have to scan this you
know with the Drone and maybe we can
start to really map out all these
different
features okay so this is where we're at
right now there are 90 plus structures
all manmade from here all the way down
south yeah ex all the way to there yes
so a huge area it is
huge you can't see anything it's all
Mangrove are the mangroves here 800
years ago no I doubt it it's been
abandoned for a long time so mang just
it would have been easier to map it then
than it is now well that's why we have
Li right then delete the
mangroves take it
off my drone begin the first of more
than 40 planned
flights we're scanning this whole area
almost half a square mile twice the size
of the Vatican
City we want to strip back the jungle
canopy and reveal the rest of this
city I'm going back to explore the
gigantic building that Gus showed me to
find out more about the people who built
this
place why is there so little known about
people that built this incredible
Monument the reason there are so little
known is because there's not a a written
system to express ideas it's through
oral tradition which are the stories
exactly those are stories handed down
generation to generation and no person
can tell the entire story because
there's the belief that if they tell the
whole story that they will die they're
no longer
useful how was this place built I can't
imagine how human effort could actually
carry these Stones all the way up to the
top of this building it's really not
clear to us how it was done the physics
part of it one Legend talks about magic
being used to lift the rocks and bring
them over here so they would fly magic
flew these rocks here that's
right this whole Expedition is something
else
I'm a scientist a technologist I deal in
facts finding out how they actually
built this it's going to be a
challenge but deeper into the ritual
complex we spot something
familiar here we have a sakao pounding
Stone remember from the sakao ceremony
with the N Marquee you can tell because
of the circular wear pattern so you're
telling me that people used to sit
around this Stone
and pounds a cow right at the entrance
to this complex this is like a Gateway
sort of ceremony it's a like a r of
Passage and how you get to know people
and this is the same thing that's been
going on for centuries yeah at least
centuries if not a thousand
years at the very center the true
purpose of this stone monument is
revealed wow
this tomb housed the bones of the selor
the leader at the time for the whole
island where were they found do you know
um some of them were inside of the walls
between the
rocks it wasn't a single body found here
but the partial remains of many people
perhaps spanning
Generations what do you know about the
sador the stories tell us that the
selors had a b bit of a bad reputation
and they didn't exactly treat everyone
so well and this is literally the heart
of the whole complex that's
right it sits within a huge tomb
District at this end of Nadol a Valley
of the Kings on
water you know it's very different
than a Stone heads of Easter Island but
just like there this place right here is
built honor the spirits of the
Dead spirits that the locals believe
still reside
here the tombs we can see are only a
fragment of
Nadol our lar scans should reveal a
whole lot
more
hidden somewhere under half a square
mile of tropical jungle lies the ancient
city of
nador we're laser scanning the area with
light on to create a blueprint of the
city to uncover its structures and help
us understand why the sador Kings built
it hacking Through the Jungle taking
this massive drone and launching from
every point they could in a methodical
grid pattern it's going to take some
time for the processing to finish so
that we can remove the trees but we've
got the first scans in let's pull them
in oh wow
you that's pretty awesome right amazing
even before we remove the trees you get
a sense of this network of geometric
shapes that Define the human structures
right you can already see faintly here
here here and then here's a main it that
you took me to earlier so you can
already start to piece together this
whole city or what was once there it's a
glimpse into an ancient city of tombs
and
temples see what is this look how
straight those lines are you see that
look at that they're perfectly
uniform such a regular shape that that
can't be
natural that's
incredible I want to check them
out the mang is really tense so I mean
there's no way for us to walk in there
you know it's
impossible unless you go by a
boat we're headed back to Nadol now this
time by
SE this is how they would have
approached here hundreds of years
ago I followed my GPS to the spot that
we identified on the liar
scans look at
those can we get in right
[Music]
there wow these are
unreal these are huge
rocks it's bigger than anything else
I've seen
here I just can't wrap my head around
how they would have got them here and
then lifted them one upon another it's
just
insane you know each one of these
Boulders must weigh the amount of a
couple of buses at
least this is something Beyond
imagination so
[Music]
weird
the line of rocks takes me deeper into
the
mangroves it's
enormous and it goes on
forever the man-made structure captured
by the Light Art is a seaw
wall
built on Coral Reef it stretches for a
mile and a
quarter it's almost like a giant
Fortress more than a
city we can now Define the boundaries of
the city on three
[Music]
sides entering through a break in the
wall there are hints of more ancient
Basalt buildings lining the main
Channel It's like a Master Mason
designed the whole thing but they didn't
use mortar they just placed everything
in a perfect
balance still intact 800 years or so
after a
construction it's getting very narrow
here we're looking for our passageway
but the mangr have just grown
[Music]
everywhere
is it okay to enter this area it's too
risky for you to get off why is that
risky in the afternoon time there are
spirits around these islands guarding
these places you don't want to get
sick you know in respect for local
Traditions I think we're going to keep
going this is where old school
exploration ends and tomorrow
my technology takes
over by stripping these trees away with
our lar we'll see what this wall is
[Music]
protecting we've discovered hints of
what amadol looks like but the full
extent of this mysterious city has been
shrouded for centuries in Island Legend
and mangrove forest
technology can change that the lar scans
are complete the Hope here is that
you're going to see namad as it was
originally before all these trees took
over we're getting a view of the entire
site because you can't see it unless you
do something like this this is the lar
before the trees have been
removed you ready for this
yes look at that you see oh wow look at
that it's crazy right that's another
structure for sure you think there
structures that you've never seen before
yes definitely just from this picture
about 10 because you know it's really
inaccessible so with this we're able to
go where you can't go
yes this is
incredible do you know are there stories
of this place of course each structure
has a function this one is the
residental area for the out so this this
is where they lived you can realize that
the entire area is protected by the seaw
wall what were they defending themselves
against not only I guess natural
elements but probably
people up to 2,000 people lior but these
were the
rulers you can imagine how impressive
this would have been just the scale it's
amazing this was happening some 800
years ago exactly exactly on this island
in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean we can now digitally rebuild what
Nadol may have looked like in all of its
Glory a colossal seaw wall protects over
90 man-made Islands organized into a
burial district and a residential
Zone with temple and monuments
signifying the power of the oppressive
selur rulers who lived
[Music]
here so we have a 3D digital model of
the height of all of these different
features from that we can get a precise
measurement based off this actual data
of how much volume of material this
place took to
build we begin with the single largest
ruin in the city the ceremonial tomb
site I
visited we've just looked at the main
exterior wall as an initial calculation
what I've done here is just take a
simple section and from this we're
looking at over 14,000 tons of
bass that's just the outside was not
even the whole structure and the tombs
and stuff
inside 14,000 tons it's crazy I know
right based on the lar data the amount
of rock used used to build the entire
city is nearly
700,000
tons its ancient construction on an
unimaginable
scale but where did those thousands of
Rocks come
from for centuries it's been explained
by
[Music]
Magic on the The Far Side of the island
is a BT deposit that may hold the answer
is that it that's it that's the
baby it's a Cory like no
other it just poked straight out of the
trees this is a COR in the
sky I think we could fly the Drone right
out of here and do a big pass arounded
ready I want to get a close look at this
extraordinary volcanic
mine incredibly it looks as if it's been
mined from the
top there must be a way that these
ancient Islanders climbed up and got the
stones
down I don't think we can make it all
the way to the
top but there's a spot right in the
middle of the mountain that we made be
able to
access
this way maybe this
way you okay yeah I'm good it's a 400t
scramble that starts Steep and quickly
becomes almost vertical be careful har
some rocks here
[Music]
slippery this is where they got the
rocks from yep pretty intense
Cory this is the real deal
bro we're almost there all right 50 ft
from the summit we reach what appears to
be the main quy
site these are
unreal they look exactly like the ones
in amodel the same hexagonal shape Yep
this is like the stone Log Cabin
hardware store for the
island they didn't have d Dynamite or
anything like that back then how would
they actually break these off one of the
theories is that you burn wood and you
bore water in it will crack or it
expands so they were like uh almost like
material scientists back then yes
Engineers how much does one of these
weigh the typical ones they use an NAD
between 5 to 10 tons but there are bers
that can weigh up to 50 tons how far is
NAD from here uh 10 miles across the
land straight 10 Mi that way
yes
just doesn't make any sense let's go a
little further I'm going to try to see
if I can get up there and and get a view
okay good luck you're not coming I'm not
coming I'll be right back be careful
[Music]
now people came all the way over here to
the north side of the island somehow
climbed this mountain broke off these
massive Stone pillars and then
transported them across the
island
just like on Easter Island over 6,000 M
away people here moved mountains of
volcanic rock to build extraordinary
monuments that they believed could
connect them to the
[Music]
spirits this is perfect you can see
everything the whole are
area maybe I can start to see exactly
what route they might have taken with
these rocks no I'm going to look on the
satellite images here okay so
I'm I think right here on top of this
mountain they had to get the Rocks all
the way over to here to namad I couldn't
imagine carrying a 5 or 10 ton Boulder
over that mountain behind
me doesn't seem possible at all
okay My View From The Summit suggests an
alternative
route a trail of mangroves leads
straight into the
ocean and we know where there's
mangroves there's
water the way that would be most logical
is they might have broken these Boulders
Off thrown them down to the bottom of
this Quarry and then somehow use the
mangroves and the chanels to get them
out if they could float them out to sea
maybe they would move them across the
inside of that re Reef where the waves
aren't so bad and then it's a decision
do you go north all the way around the
island that way or do you go
south I guess depends on the winds the
tides and the
distance and actually you know honestly
like super sophisticated in terms of
whatever engineering they had to come up
with to make that
[Music]
possible at the moment it's a
theory but there are intriguing legends
that tell of a stone City of the Dead
beneath the
waves it's in route from here to
Nadol and it could provide evidence of
how the city was really
[Music]
built we're headed to a site that has
been described as a underwater city of
the dead or of the Gods still inhabited
today with Spirits you know most locals
they won't even come here to fish
because is
taboo you know we're waiting into
uncharted waters in some
ways we're searching an area just east
of namol where the shallow Reef drops
away into the deep water you can start
to see the outer walls in front of us
off the starboard a little bit
1:00
our ladder can't penetrate
water so we're using downscan Sonar
which can detect what's on the sea floor
to a depth of up to 300
ft here as we're motoring along making a
grid pattern around the entrance of
Nadol the sonar is setting a ping
straight down it'll hit something and
it'll return back like a
reflection basically these little blocks
it's just a school of fish right here
I'm just looking for anything that might
look man-made something
that's maybe geometric in
nature after about 30 minutes of
scanning look at that look at that
that's beautiful a big spike we're right
on top of it now you got C Flor C Flor C
floor and then all a sudden boom this
spike in elevation right here right
underneath us
whether it's manmade or not that's why
we're diving on
it let's mark this point right here
straight on okay we'll drop in close to
the entrance to Nadal and then swim out
looking for the
structure dive fo is that thing M eyes
should be right that's the next one
that's the upgrade yeah three years ago
I was sitting in a hospital bed
wondering if I'd ever walk again now I'm
about to Dawn a scuba diving kit and Dro
into an ocean we're going to look for a
lost
city it's just Barren down here there's
not a lot of
fish oh it's
murky so if they see Basel rock down
there I mean that's evidence that this
place was man-made or manb built Basel
rocks are volcanic rocks they're not
coral reefs it's out of place if we find
it de somebody brought a
de we start our search grid close to the
outer wall of
Nadol that's D all right
there you can see the seaw wall
further from the wall I spot something
familiar look the same hexagonal Stones
right
here
incredible these Basalt columns don't
look like they're part of the
construction they're random like they
might have ended up here
accidentally we move away from The Reef
shelf to the deeper water our key search
area
check this
out this must be what we saw in the
sodar oh man it's got to be about 20 ft
tall they're kind of one after the other
here just pumping up out of the sea4 In
This Very vertical
Direction I really can't be sure this is
natural
or something manmade
either way it's spooky
[Music]
looking you know it's pretty incredible
down there I did see piles of assault
Rock closer to nador and along the side
of the wall are these huge pillars that
just rise out of the out of the depths
like Shadows of giants through this
murky
water
but it's to me
inconclusive you know it could be
natural forming Reef or Coral heads or
it could be Bal incrusted with floral
it's hard to say
the whatever it is it's
weird very very strange down there very
strange that's a huge column there
that's got to be at least 30 ft tall
have you seen other Coral pillars like
this before this is the only place that
I've seen pillars like that I've never
seen Coral grow in a vertical column
like that unless there's something for
it to grow
onto the strange vertical pillars remain
a mystery but are the likely source of
the underwater city
myth the hexagonal columns lying on the
sea Flor May support the theory
that the building blocks of Nadol were
brought here by
sea if the architects of Nadol could
sail giant rocks around the island just
how far could their Kingdom have
[Music]
reached we think that the giant assault
blocks of namol were transported by sea
I'm hunting for evidence that the
Islanders may have sailed further a
field 20 M from here is a string of tiny
islands called Ant
atle I found only one report of this
whole place it was written from before
the time I was born and it describes
something that I've got to check out
that's just beyond the
reef
this report claims that somewhere on
these islands are traces of an ancient
civilization the head of the family who
now protects ant antle is Willie Holly
he has a traditional title of
Rosa welcome to ant thank you your
family has been on this island for a
long time over 100 years that's what our
clan is to
these are awesome I need a
tattoo this area of the island has been
abandoned for decades but as a boy Rosa
remembers seeing unusual Stones here I
don't know how you can find anything
with all this undergrowth you're
starting to see the balt rocks here yeah
that is not common for an up like this
these are the same basalt rocks that I
saw at neodo there's no quy of Basalt
sitting out here somewhere in this atle
is there there is not this isn't the
only intriguing Remnant here of an
ancient
civilization all right we're at it you
found it
yeah if you look they're Flat Rocks
overgrown with trees and stuff but if
you thrush it off and you'll take a look
at it it's sakow
Stone oh I saw one just like this right
at the entrance of namad and the first
thing I did was sit with the N Marquee
to a CA ceremony where Stones were
pounding just like this to make the
ca you can see this is so deep this must
have been hundreds of Cal ceremonies oh
yeah thousands
maybe where did these stones come
from I would say pumy so somehow the
technology that they had in
understanding of the sea allowed them to
bring huge Boulders across waves and
reefs and miles of ocean just to to get
here is it possible that these were the
same people that built
namad has to be I can't see any any
other reason why this would actually be
here unless there was a link between
here and
there here here's another one right here
bigger
one I think there probably would have
been some type of a settlement here wow
how big do you think this
is that's the
mystery
clearing this site by hand could take
[Music]
weeks our liar scanner will digitally
strip away some of the
vegetation just like our scan at amadol
if there's anything lurking beneath the
undergrowth this will find
[Music]
it the guys have processed all the data
that I got from the scan out on Ant atle
and here it is so I zoom in here and
this is the track that I
walked but I can actually kind of move
down through the layers and clear away
the trees a little bit then you can
actually see this really incredible
blueprint of this sight that darker area
right there these are Cal Stones those
are the pounding Stones 1 2 3 4 5 6 in a
circle all around this one area you can
imagine how big of a ceremonial place
this must have been because I've only
seen one or two Cal Stones next to each
other this is six right
here 20 M away from amadol Ant ATL was
home to a huge ritual site perhaps built
by the very same people it's evidence
that Nadol had influence that stretched
across the
waves what's really incredible about
this is that it's on a tiny spe of sand
beyond the Barrier Reef which means that
what happened here happened elsewhere as
well there are
25,000 other Islands across the Pacific
trade and culture traveled from Island
to Island but just how far did this
ocean Network
reach nad's architects were highly
skilled
seafarers capable of moving rocks miles
across the
ocean but could they have been part of a
much bigger trans-pacific
[Music]
movement Anthropologist Ashley Meredith
has uncovered some evidence that might
help answer this
question ready yeah
oh my
goodness it's quite a large field
eh it's amazing the outcrop that we're
exploring is actually a gallery filled
with ancient rock
[Music]
art it's creepy looks almost like a
ghost look at that there's a sword down
there how long ago were these carved
this could be uh 1 to 2,000 years ago
okay 2,000 years ago that's the time
when story of Christ was happening
that's the time when the first emperor
of China was building the Terracotta
Army and here in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean somebody actually carved
this into this Stone and contemplated
their
reality this rock art shows that pom hey
was an important cultural site even
before the Satur
[Music]
arrived ready this is my favorite
waa wow how did you find this through
oral history there are stories here that
talk about foreigners making these
foreigners mhm where these people came
from we can't be sure you see these to
anywhere else similar new calonia wait
wait how far away is New calonia New
calonia is about 2,000 miles from here
2,000 mies yep that's like uh that's
almost the distance between New York and
La
yes if I take images from a bunch of
different angles then I can use
photogrametry where you can add up the
overlapping images and it creates a 3D
model of the
entire that's really cool
using the Digital model I can make the
faint eroded carving far more
visible check this
out is that awesome my gosh I'm actually
moving the virtual light across the
features and make them pop out a little
more see yeah that was a good one right
there slowly slow there right there yes
that's really cool you can see more of
the detail let me just screen grab this
all right right so now I can pull the
same thing up over here okay this is the
image from UK
calonia that's right okay so this is
from
here they have a lot in common let see
maybe I can actually do something even
crazier I can change the
opacity I can move it on top of the
other
image H look at that whoa they're like
they're really
similar that's awesome right yeah it's
almost a perfect print one of the other
I'm staring at these two images and to
me it's just too similar to be a
coincidence how could something a nearly
identical pop up 2,000 mil away but in a
time when sailing across those distances
must have been incredibly
difficult there's no GPS it's just old
school
navigation
whether or not these two symbols were
created by the same Pacific people it's
clear evidence that the ocean didn't
isolate these cities and these cultures
it connected
them the sadders ruled for 400 years
until they were
overthrown and within those centuries
their seaf fairing skills took them
across the Pacific who knows maybe even
as far as that other great civilization
on Easter is Island over 6,000 M
away both left their Mark set in
stone this Lost City built on water is
more Grand and complex than I ever
imagined a seat of power for the ruling
Elite part of a great network of people
who traveled north south east and west
across the vast Pacific
[Music]
Ocean this place it came from a meeting
of peoples who sailed across the seas
with skill and bravery Beyond
Comprehension and with them They Carried
ideas creating an ocean continent in a
way leaving traces of the human spirit
in these massive mysterious Stone
monuments the the lost city of nador
it's more than an archaeological Wonder
it's a monument to human
[Music]
possibility